ASSEMBLYMEMBER CALDERON NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM. THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. HURRY
ARAMBULA. BAUER-KAHAN BERMAN.
BIGELOW BLOOM. BOERNER HORVATH
BONTA BRO BURKE CALDERON
CARRILLO CERVANTES CHAU CHEN
DAVID CHIU CHOI KANSEN CHU
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY
DALY DEEP. EGGMAN FLORA FONG
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GABRIEL
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON GLORIA
GONZALEZ IS GRAY GRAYSON HOLDEN
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KAMLAGER KILEY LACKEY LEVINE
LIMON LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ
MULLIN MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RAY IS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ. RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SMITH STONE TEEN
VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WICKS WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER.
YOU KNOW.
YEAH.
EVERYTHING. AND. RIGHT.
YOU.
SB NATION WITH.
YEAH.
YOU
CAN.
YEAH.
SO.
MEMBERS A QUORUM
IS PRESENT. MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY.
THERE
IS A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS A QUORUM IS PRESENT
IN THE ASSEMBLY.
MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO BEGIN THE PROCEEDINGS.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT. WE
ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER. AND IN
THE GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR
THE PRAYER. ONCE AGAIN WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER. AND IN THE
GALLERY. TO PLEASE STAND FOR
THE PRAYER. TODAY'S PRAYER WILL
BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN REVEREND PATTY OSHA
RIVER GHOST. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
A MOMENT OF REFLECTION. IT IS
INTERESTING THAT CONFUCIUS SAID
ONE WHO WISHES TO TEACH OR TO
LEAD OTHERS SHOULD PLAY MUSIC
FOR FOUR HOURS A DAY. IS ALSO
SAID THAT THE HISTORICAL BUDDHA
WITH ENGAGE IN SOLITARY
MEDITATION FOR FOUR HOURS A DAY.
INTERESTINGLY ARCHBISHOP
DESMOND TUTU BEGINS EACH DATE
WITH FOUR HOURS OF QUIET PRAYER.
WEATHER IS PLAYING MUSIC
MEDITATING OR PRAYING THE
SPIRITUAL MASTERS ENCOURAGE THE
NEED TO ENGAGE IN CALMING SELF
REFLECTION TO HELP REMAIN
CENTERED. IN TRYING TO PLAY
MUSIC WE NATURALLY REFLECT ON
HOW WE FEEL. IS IMPOSSIBLE TO
PLAY WHEN WE ARE ANGRY OR PRE
OCCUPIED SO TO IS IT IMPOSSIBLE
TO MEDITATE OR PRAY WHEN WE ARE
UPSET DISTRACTED OR I'M
FOCUSED. THE GREATER THE
RESPONSIBILITIES OF LEADERSHIP
THE MORE THERE IS A NEED FOR
DEEP IN QUIET REFLECTION IN
EACH DAY. REMEMBERING AGAIN THE
HUMILITY IT TAKES TO TRULY
LEAD. LET US ALL EMBRACE OUR
RESPONSIBILITY OF LEADERSHIP
BUT DALY REFLECTION. WHETHER IT
IS WITH MUSIC MEDITATION OR
PRAYER. SELF REFLECTION CAN
HELP KEEP US FOCUSED AND I'M
DISTRACTED AS WE CONTINUE TO
TRY TO SET THE BAR OF
LEADERSHIP HI. NUMBER ONE THE
NUMBER TWO WITH KINDNESS AND
GRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS. THANK
YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING
AND JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THREE OF US SHE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER REED. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO BUY. IN AMERICA.
WHICH IS ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. THANK YOU YOU
MAY BE SEATED. READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL. THE
CHAMBER SACRAMENTO TUESDAY
FEBRUARY ELEVENTH TWENTY TWENTY
RECENTLY MET AT SEVEN AM UNTIL
AT CHAO ASSEMBLY MEMBER FORTY
NINE JUST PRESIDING CHEAPER TO
PARKER AT THE DESK BE QUICK
CUNNINGHAM LOSE READING THE
BALLING THE PLACE ON THE
MORNING ROLL CALL AGUIAR-CURRY
ARAMBULA BAUER-KAHAN BERMAN
BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH BONTA
BROUGH CALDERON CARILLO CHILD
CHANGED CALDERON MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS THAT THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS AMPUTATION THERE
ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE RECEIVED DURING THE JOINT
CONVENTION. MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE THERE ARE NONE. MOVING
TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
TODAY'S ABSENCES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
IF YOU HAVE NOT ALREADY SILENCE
YOUR MOBILE PHONES PLEASE DO SO
AT THIS TIME. THE SILENCE YOUR
PHONES.
THERE WAS WARY
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTION MEMBERS.
MISTER CALDERON THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE ONE EIGHTEEN A TO
ALLOW SPEAKER RENDON TO HAVE
GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE
FLOOR AT THE ROSTRUM AND IN THE
GALLERY FOR THE GOVERNOR'S.
STATE OF THE STATE ADDRESS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE REQUEST
IS GRANTED. WE WILL NOW RECESS
THE REGULAR SESSION AND CONVENE
THE JOINT CONVENTION. EVERYONE
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS. HERE.
THE GOVERNOR HAS ARRIVED I AM
APPOINTING A JOINT COMMITTEE TO
ESCORT THE GOVERNOR TO THE
RESTAURANT THE FOLLOWING
MEMBERS SHOULD RETIRE TO THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS CALDERON. BAUER-KAHAN
BERMAN KANSEN CHU DOLLY AND
CALM WATER. SENATORS WEST SO.
WIENER LENA GONZALEZ BATES
MITCHELL AND WHITE CASKET.
AND.